disait david vous vous suivait le
cortège de la manifestation organisée
par florian philippot est ce que son
appel a été entendu aujourd'hui oui un
millier de personnes amira se diriger
actuellement maintenant vers la place
vauban ils sont partis de la place
joffre pour diriger vers la place moment
un cortège et un cortège de muni de
nombreux manifestants acquis et sont
présents ici pour protester un contenu
tension de ce pas sanitaire florian
philippot à l'initiative de ce
rassemblement a harangué la foule en
disant que c'était le 38e samedi
consécutif que les manifestants étaient
dans la rue pour protester contre ce
passé sanitaires voilà de nombreux
manifestants ici qui sont en colère à
vous l'aurez compris un vis-à-vis de
l'extension se passe à l'état et la
validation du conseil constitutionnel
par par les sages
finalement de ce pass sanitaire qui sera
nécessaire pour accéder à des lieux de
la vie quotidienne
à savoir que la plupart des manifestants
présents ici ne sont pas contre la
vaccination mais vraiment réellement un
contre l'obligation de se passe
sanitaire de ce côté à florian philippot
est heureux de voir que la mobilisation
se poursuit à chaque samedi dans la
revue écouter les gens ont vu qu'ils
étaient travaillés attaquer par toutes
leurs institutions du parlement au
gouvernement en passant par le conseil
d'état et le conseil constitutionnel
bien sûr mais le souverain en france ce
ne sont pas eux c'est le peuple et le
peuple de france va rappeler va rappeler
très fortement aujourd'hui ici à paris
partout en france que le souverain c'est
lui qui ne veut pas d'une société
d'apartheid qui ne veut pas une société
de ségrégation et de séparation qui ne
veut pas une société liberticide
il veut qu'on revienne vers quelque
chose de beaucoup plus humain et de
beaucoup plus conforme à nos valeurs
en tête de cortège se trouve également
le président de debout la france nicolas
dupont aignan venus soutenir cette
mobilisation et ce rassemblement qui est
encadré par un important dispositif de
sécurité
je rappelle que le préfet didier
lallement a mobilisé près de 3000
policiers et gendarmes pour les
multiples mobilisations qui a se déroule
dans la capitale
objectif est qu'il n'ya aucun
débordement pour rappel la semaine
dernière 26 interpellations ont eu lieu
pour le moment aucun débordement à
signaler des slogans hostiles envers le
président français est également des
pancartes liberté qui sont qui sont
acquis qui apparaissent à travers à
travers cette mobilisation et cette
manifestation je vous le disais qu'ils
se dirigent vers un place vauban l'idée
également et de rejoindre les autres
cortèges pour donner une impression de
mobilisation forte face à l'extension de
ce pass annie terre